alors ce lynch ben disons que ça a l'air
mangeable et au repérage se donne quoi
ça va ce qu'écoutent et ben tu vois les
quatre crétins qui te mettais dans la
cour ils sont en terminale ils
organisent la fête de fin d'année
surtout rappelle moi de paille eric
legros à casquette là bas si le
capitaine de l'équipe de rugby il ferait
n'importe quoi pour avoir des bonnes
notes en maths il est pote avec jimi
hendrix qui est amoureux de la fille au
ruban rose dans les rues et la fille la
sortie tout droit de gotham city
elle tient le trafic de club pour tout
le lycée et de près de la fenêtre en
train de bosser c'est les soeurs dessus
fils de [ __ ] qui joue les caïds en coin
là bas c'est lui qui t'a arranger le
lien ouais mais je le reste inquiète je
connais son point faible c'est quoi il
cherche une sono pour sa fête dans deux
semaines il ya qu un seul gars qui peut
lui fournir le matos c'est une tête le
fils d'un ingénieur tu le vois si tout
seul là bas pas perdu tant dis moi j'ai
pas de temps à perdre